air quality and climate change will be  on the agenda of the environment council  meeting taking place and Luxembourg on  15 june the council will look at the new  rules to limit emissions of pollutants  into the air and at the preparations for  the upcoming UN climate change  conference the proposed NEC directive on  National emission ceilings is part of  the clean air program for Europe it aims  at significantly improving air quality  in the EU by 2020 in preparation for the  UN climate change conference in Paris  this December Minister will exchange  their views on key issues on the  international climate negotiations the  debate will contribute to set out de use  position for the conference the aim of  the Paris conference is to adopt a  legally binding agreement to be  implemented from 2020 this agreement  should ensure that the global  temperature increase stays below 2  degrees Celsius relative to  pre-industrial levels